greetings from Corona Ville take this
[ __ ] muley
[Music]
but they bought it dirty at the March
stop substance it's a beautiful day to
be alive
Uncle Joe we're here from the Voodoo
Lounge the christ-killers here it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day hey Elvis is dead
no I don't feel so good myself I know
everybody's got problems it's a whole
new week it's a whole new week of
quarantine and I can't fly into New York
New Jersey of Connecticut
things are [ __ ] up but that don't mean
you have to be [ __ ] up okay there's
still things going on a lot of people
are rioting they're still in off like
you're done listen it's gonna be a hard
time and I'm gonna tell you when you
[ __ ] drop an atomic bomb who survives
cockroaches cockroaches survive right
now they've just dropped dropped an
atomic bomb on us and the people who are
gonna survive are gonna be people who
were [ __ ] thinking outside the box I
know a lot of years the scan I'm here
scared with you are we scared of a virus
what the [ __ ] are we even scared of then
have you even decided what the [ __ ] you
scared are you scared of your financial
help are you scared of your help
are you scared for your parents I mean I
got I've heard a thousand horror stories
this week I have dear friends in Florida
that I had dear friends I grew up with
in Jersey at their mother moved to
Florida she had a stroke my Frank my
heart goes out to them and they're
pulling the plug on Monday they can't
fly down there they go see their mother
so you want to come to me with a little
motion story go [ __ ] yourself okay it's
gonna be tough times and let me see let
me tell you some tough people are our
last tough [ __ ] times it's the year
of the [ __ ] hustler
so whatever the [ __ ] you're thinking I'm
thinking you got to think outside the
box right now you got a family you don't
have a family you got to think outside
the box
traditional ways are over if you sit
there waiting for an unemployment check
or if you're sitting there waiting for
that [ __ ] stimulus go [ __ ] yourself
you got a better chance of getting raped
by 10 [ __ ] ugh Wu hen [ __ ]
without the wool and disease you know
I'm saying so this is what I'm gonna
tell you right now [ __ ] all that [ __ ] go
to your nearest supermarket they're
hiring Walmart's hiring shop rights
hiring [ __ ] or Amazon's hiring I
don't want to hear none of your [ __ ]
that you're going broke
there's no reason to go broke there's a
thousand [ __ ] angles right now
you just have to step up to the pump
swallow remove your [ __ ] pride put
your dream on [ __ ] hold ya but Joey I
wanted to be a figure skater yeah well
that's over with right now so now we
gotta go stock show is the [ __ ] shop
right for now for now you know I mean
right now where's the stand
where's the Futurist and up where's the
Futurist stand up what do you think
we're just gonna go back to being
[ __ ] ha-joon people gonna be hurt and
people are hurting right now there's
seriously people hurting and my heart
goes out to you but I'm gonna give you
the solution to how to get the [ __ ] out
of this mess right now first off we're
not in a mess if you're a [ __ ] savage
you know this is everyday for
[ __ ] like this life is [ __ ]
problems how to eliminate [ __ ] the
problems is what you do every day how to
keep your problems to a minimum that's
what you strive for every day so this is
not a problem what's going on this is
just a situation this is a time period
in your life so take a deep breath relax
now let's go back to basics okay
swallow your pride you know what are you
gonna do ask your father for money ask
your grandmother for money that does
days are over you're too [ __ ] old get
up off your [ __ ] ass
and think outside the box what you
always really want to do this is the
time to start it why because you have
nothing to lose
right now you have nothing so you have
nothing to lose so if you want to be a
painter go get some [ __ ] crayons
[ __ ] and start if you want to be a
singer this is the time to do it you
know you go Joey I can't get a job
singing at a restaurant nobody can now
get on line every night in the sink
[ __ ] opera I don't give a [ __ ] I got
a friend Ralph Carey I grew up with him
I applaud this [ __ ] every night
every [ __ ] Wednesday at Thursday he
does an Elvis impersonation act from his
living room and every week you see it's
like the podcast it's getting better and
better
he got curtains he's got a little
[ __ ] show now a light show he's got a
little posters of Elvis around them you
know what I sit there I take my edibles
at night and I watch it like giggle I
I applaud his [ __ ] boss he always
loved Elvis is a [ __ ] kid he wanted
me an Elvis impersonator whatever [ __ ]
you and he's doing it so I mean guys
there's no reason to be down there's no
reason to be depressed this is just
another [ __ ] day in paradise how you
navigate around it is what you have to
worry about so again all these [ __ ]
places for you people who are waiting
for a check and that 12-hour stimulus
check listen yeah I promise you I
promise you I won't come in your mouth
but I promise you the check is in the
mail
stop it you can't be that dumbest
[ __ ] Americans that check could get
lost they don't even know who the [ __ ]
you are unemployment listen they have a
hard time doing regular season and you
imagine it with a million [ __ ] claims
what they gonna go through so stop your
[ __ ] crying pick up your pants pick
up your chin go look at the mirror and
say to yourself three times I'm a bad
[ __ ]
everybody's sucking my dick today and go
out there and find something to hold you
over until this blows over listen doctor
for Yugi what's the little [ __ ] dude
from the side the one that covers his
head every time mopped Trump talks that
little [ __ ] Italian doctor doctor
Fucci [ __ ] Trump the governor in New
York there are all nice people they're
all trying really hard but they're all
not fortune tellers and they can't tell
you what's gonna happen
nobody knows what's gonna happen you as
a human being
you're smart I got a GED and I can tell
you one thing expect the worst and go
for the best that's all you could do
here this is not gonna be over in two
weeks okay
this is not gonna be over in three weeks
that's you know like when you do
something and the effects linger the
effects are gonna linger this is not
something that's this is goddamn into
America's psyche okay this that's
completely different when when you go to
a when you go see the Joker you're on
edge when you go see what's the atom of
Sailor Moon
uncut gems you're on edge for two hours
okay and then you've believed that
theater and you go back to being normal
and it was an experience that you had
right now you're experiencing that only
in real time it's your life you don't
know what's gonna happen so before you
start making predictions oh we're gonna
go to I in July we're gonna go see
Motley Crue in July don't worry about
the future think about what you could do
today to make it better and how you can
better yourself this week was surfer I
worked out Monday and Tuesday I threw my
back out after I did the Rogan podcast
had it sit for [ __ ] three hours you
guys know I'm not good at [ __ ]
sitting I'm not a professional [ __ ]
sinner I'm not good at sitting at all my
back was so [ __ ] up and I thought it
was my kidney cuz everybody says that
[ __ ] the one mom said that her son
was a perfect athlete and he got a
backache then he got a headache then he
died so all [ __ ] day Thursday and
Friday I walked around thinking I was
gonna die thinking I was gonna have to
stand on line at the [ __ ] hospital
with a bunch of people with Ebola and
I'd be there for a bad back what was I
gonna do I showed it to my wife my wife
said that my spine was crooked so I hung
up myself upside down for a little while
I put the peds on my back to tense I
loosened the muscle I couldn't even
[ __ ] get up I was making noises I
never heard before when you came over
the other night when I gave you that
edible cocktail of death right when you
fell asleep on Twitch whatever the [ __ ]
you see now I walked out I was [ __ ]
crooked I couldn't even walk I couldn't
even [ __ ] walk with two days but
that's the secret number one take care
of yourself right now a lot of zinc a
lot of vitamin C if this thing attacks
you
it's a zinc and vitamin C what are you
gonna go to dr. Fung well what's he
gonna do for you he's telling you that
stay home zinc it up and see it up every
time I walk past the cabinet I drop a
thousand milligrams of vitamin C you
piss it right out that's why I keep
popping vitamin C nobody's ever died
from vitamin C overdose okay
you know when he died of he had too much
vitamin C he ate 200 oranges that don't
kill nobody all right vitamin C is
[ __ ] good for you vitamin C that
mother [ __ ] up though some zinc in your
system every time you need to go out
when you get home gargle with warm water
and salt
that's the secret because the virus sits
in your throat for three days before it
spreads into your lungs so every time
you step outside the house
you have contact with somebody even
though they're 18 feet away I don't give
a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] when I go
home now from this podcast I lovely I
take a shower and I gargle with that
salt [ __ ] solution so nothing sets in
my throwing than at night sometimes I
hit it with Listerine because I can't
even take my own breath and on top of
that you wanna [ __ ] you can sit there
and go damn I got bad breath you play on
the computer and you smell you up a lip
and you go smells like an [ __ ] when
that you're like what the [ __ ] no I did
reefer and nicotine gum and water your
breath smells like a [ __ ] [ __ ] my
teeth are like [ __ ] magenta if I'm
scared to go to death he's gonna laugh
at me he's gonna go would you brush your
teeth with a crayon the [ __ ] is wrong
with you I brushed my teeth three times
a day and they got like the magenta
color to me I think the reef is just
[ __ ] ruin them it's 57 years what are
you gonna do you're saying I turn a
certain [ __ ] color eventually but
that's it that's that man it's Monday
[ __ ] morning it's a whole new week
you got a whole new attitude listen
we've been petrified for two weeks
stop it already your anxiety level
should drop by now cuz my anxiety level
I've accepted my fate I have I've
accepted my fate nobody else is every
time you're trying to be Nostradamus and
predict the future you know my fate is
I'm a 57 year old fat [ __ ]
okay the road doesn't look like it for a
while just doesn't look like it you
think about it if we go through straight
May what do you thinks gonna happen in
June you think all you mother [ __ ]
are gonna come out of the house and have
a bunch of money no you're not
it's gonna be a different game and on
top of that if we go through June or
[ __ ] July first they're gonna start
with ten people coming to a show then
twenty people
come into a shell then 50 people come
into a shell then 100 people and that's
gonna take a [ __ ] while and hopefully
by then we'll all be healed and let's
pray that this coronavirus doesn't come
back I'm someone with a lot of anxiety
but the one thing that saved me with
this is that I have no control and I can
take care of myself and give myself a
better chance but overall I had nothing
I can do can change this nothing I told
you guys last week this isn't your fault
this isn't my fault this isn't many
buddies fault this is a sad thing about
this nobody saw this coming
nobody [ __ ] saw this coming so on the
bright side listen man just take care of
yourselves
try to make up a clique Abby I've been
reading like a [ __ ]
I've been read Bob Lingus thank you I'm
finally catching up on some [ __ ]
reading I I'm starting on that led
Zeppelin book [ __ ] Bob Lowe Lingus
sent me a letter plan book it's bigger
than the Bible it's bigger than a
Chinese Bible you understand me it's
like 2,000 [ __ ] pages I didn't put
down like 50 pages a day so Wow
yeah this is what this is for and you
got a schedule your [ __ ] day right
now I'm homeschooling my door that
epistle this week because this week I
got a I got to work with it with math of
my way I got a quicker way I showed how
to play dice okay so I've been teaching
how to play dice for money 7-eleven
that's a quick way to think to keep it
going something different and I also
talked taught how to play blackjack now
I'm not a good black jam play I'm not a
gambler but just it's different just to
change up the teaching a little bit
adding yeah yeah so I give a we play
cards the one day the one day we play
dice I got it on a schedule 8:30
she leaves the house we walk her because
she's a [ __ ] racehorse if you don't
walk my daughter you're gonna have a
problem at 3 o'clock so she's got to go
for a walk and take her mind off the
things in the morning like a 30 minute
walk which is good I kill like [ __ ]
six points we go back home I've already
eaten breakfast and my wife takes her in
the back and they do a journal from 9:30
to [ __ ]
then at ten o'clock the computer comes
on and she does something with one
teacher till 10:30 then at 10:30 she has
a little breather she's allowed back in
the house and she [ __ ] yeah she's not
allowed in the house 10:30 keeper in the
backyard we have that little spam
bedroom though oh that studio back there
the shed right so I we take it back
there my wife set it up like an office
so she'd leave it feels like she's
actually leaving yes you know people
always say I'm gonna put an office in my
house that's a good idea
if you're a really productive person but
it's a bad idea if you're [ __ ] lazy
naturally I want you to get up and leave
no if you ever if you're a lazy person
and you have an office in your house
it's not gonna work for you it's not
gonna make a big difference because
you're never gonna use anyway I always
forced myself to leave leave my office
is the coffee shop sorry I can't go to
the coffee shop so some mornings I come
here and I try the [ __ ] right for an
hour some warnings some mornings I just
sent my [ __ ] car by the park and I
bring a notebook and I write my little
journal in there while they're doing
that this whole thing is scheduling your
day you know you got two bedrooms one
bedroom go to one corner of the room for
an hour go to the other corner of the
room you know what domestic violence has
got up you know why because you people
in front of each other every [ __ ] day
me and my wife separate Jackie and I
don't have no [ __ ] big house I leave
I leave I go out I get vitamin D yeah
they Joe Rogan said to me dog you look
like you're getting a son behind the Sun
all [ __ ] week that's all I do is get
vitamin D I'm from an island the Sun
agrees with me I'm not gonna die from
vitamin D my [ __ ] DNA is an island
and Africans so what the [ __ ] we're
outside all day there's palm trees
everybody in cube is dark right you ever
see anybody ever seeing light-skinned
Cubans no they got no SPF everybody's
[ __ ] dark and that's what happens so
I'm used to the [ __ ] Sun I love it I
try to avoid my wife you know right now
I'm trying to be you know I knew the
situation you're gonna put two people
together three people together
in a house that's a [ __ ] powder cake
yeah okay and don't get me wrong we've
had Thursday night there was a little
blonde at the house you know Mercy Mercy
is uh she's seven years old she can't
wrap her head around this she really
doesn't understand how what's going on
you know she for a little while she
wouldn't even leave the house for a
couple days I had a forger to leave the
[ __ ] house yesterday Saturday
saturday Saturday I took him down a
Hollywood I took like a let's go get
dressed we're going on Hollywood you're
like why I know cuz we can't sit in the
valley another [ __ ] day I haven't
been over the hill since March 7 so I
took him into Hollywood in the afternoon
guys it was a shock of [ __ ] reality
my anxiety was under control and I
[ __ ] it shot back up again because it
was just homeless tents and in and out
had the biggest [ __ ] line you've ever
seen in your life that's all that was
out was homeless tents and aligned for
in and out that ran all the way down
Sunset I guess in and out is good during
the corona virus because you can [ __ ]
smile I didn't read that and get the
memo all of a sudden [ __ ] in and out
surprised you didn't take water balloons
and go down the line with your family
it's just I just felt so bad for those
people that use such a [ __ ] sucker
and this is why all this is happening
can you imagine if your last meals in
and out how bad you feel Oh like a
[ __ ] idiot
but these [ __ ] goo boots is think you
know I don't know but they can't go a
day without a [ __ ] burger a day
without a [ __ ] burger I mean if you
would have seen this line you would have
died okay
it went all the way outside all with a
Sunset Boulevard all the way to the big
Street Highland whoa
this is like blocks people there's like
in and out if you're not from here is
bad normally bad door but that's like a
couple blocks a [ __ ] hour wait they
were saying [ __ ] you our [ __ ] wait
and I don't go in and out I would suck
the light and I just yelled at the guy
and the guy who was it's an owl look at
the line I go holy [ __ ] that was all
that was open I I haven't I never used
to cook anything
I haven't gotten a restaurant yet and I
wonder I went to a Walmart a couple
times and that is even from now I
finally found a place that'll deliver
that all the delivery places I normally
get delivery from like grocery stores
and Amazon have been shut down yeah
they'd be shut down and now that we live
off both of them come on back we go to
the store but we don't go to any of the
big stores I'm not gonna tell you where
I go cuz then I reveal though I found a
little Mexican bodega
oh nice shrimp no I'm eat I don't know
you're gonna say no but I heard I heard
the Asian markets they're kind of dead
will you trust that I don't know I don't
know what is an Asian market
I know I found I was driving the other
day and I saw this little Mexican
supermarket I saw the parking lot was
empty trying to sort of and I drove in I
put my little mascot I got my little
[ __ ] Lysol I carry with me and I
[ __ ] went in there on a mission and
it was empty
nice I got a couple pounds of shrimp ooh
I got a couple pounds of steak I got
toilet paper
I got Lysol they had everything it's
like everybody goes to one place yeah
I've never seen people so [ __ ] stupid
stupid but I'm driving 20 miles to go to
Walmart dupit just to avoid the big city
all you gotta do is go up Lankershim and
you find these little Mexican bodegas
yeah it's empty
Wow three four people they do it right
the Mexicans are doing it right believe
it or not the Mexicans are doing it
right well because they have to work so
they they were in there [ __ ] scrub
and wiping people with masks on I mean
they were walking the aisles were empty
they have a guy outside there's only
eight people on the store right I think
I was in there with three people Thanks
no that's uh
I know as a fact I don't know if it's
cause I'm fat or not but that's the one
thing that's been scaring me it's like
not being able to leave your house to
get food
what do you mean the supermarket anyway
like like if they say you can't leave
your house or even I don't know I'm just
just just the idea I think like that's
just that you can't live you live the
lot your life the way you want to and
you just have to be cautious yeah right
now in a situation where you have to
think about the people around you I can
honestly tell you I could look you in
the eye and tell you I have not been
around any groups bigger than three or
four just a second of March Wow
once I heard about this I avoid the
people it's over it's over
we're quarantine and I don't know what
you're touching so why take the chance
why take the chance I would hate for
somebody to come in here and sit in that
chair and get it from me or for
something they're coming here and give
it to me
right I would hate to have the guilt of
me giving it to somebody because I was
selfish and unkind and careless so for
now I keep it to a minimum I know it's
different cuz you have a family but even
what you always joke about like hey like
you're a single kid and you go go to an
island cranberry juice and stuff like
with that with all the anxieties they've
taken away are you enjoying the
quarantine a little bit like look to be
able to sit down a little bit and be by
yourself here's the positives from me of
this quarantine I've been going out at
night
it's just 1976 damn you guys gotta
remember my mother had a ball so when I
was growing up in the summers I didn't
have a sitter I would stay at the bar
with my mother till 3:00 in the morning
and then I lost my mother at 16 and I
was forced to go on every night I was
forced to hang out in bars I was forced
to do things that I would never do
the circumstances I was talking to a
friend of mine the other day and he's
kind of a drink a good guy I love him to
death
his daughter plays of mercy good guy him
and his wife for good people and we were
talking about bars I'm like the good
thing about me is dog I've hated [ __ ]
bars it's just the beginning of time
like I grew up in a bar I see the effect
on alcohol on people I would see people
walking looking normal and leave and
acting like a [ __ ] jerk-off and I
made a mental note and I didn't want to
act like that
those bar regulars have always tortured
me to death regulars of the bar they
torture me to death ah I got into comedy
in 91 1991 I fell in love with something
more than I have a love myself even
that's how much I fell in love with
Tommy I was I was very lucky to get on
stage and find what I wanted to do a lot
of people lived their life and they
don't find what they truly loved okay
when I fell in love with Tommy
I fell in love head over [ __ ] heels
have you fallen in love with something
head over heels guys your fall in love
with a woman ladies you're the fall in
love with a man he'll over heels where
you forget to take care of yourself you
forget to eat you'll forget anything for
that person this is what happened to me
with comedy when comedy came into my
life I was so [ __ ] happy and I went
out every night and I stayed out and
even when I got home I read books on
comedy
I read biographies on comedy I you know
I watched [ __ ] VHS tapes endlessly
I became a 24-hour [ __ ] comic you know
everything I all I could think about was
sleep eat and [ __ ] Tommy that's all I
did
and then 95 I got into it even harder
what does that mean that means that you
don't even watch TV that means that you
already tell people [ __ ] you and your
[ __ ] wedding you know it's a [ __ ]
sad I don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about you're you
know you just tell people I'm not coming
to this I'm not doing this like this is
how much you get into comedy you know
and and I just took him off with it and
the first time I took a breather from
that from 91 the first time I took a
breather was when the longest shark came
out in May of 2005 I wasn't what does a
breather mean a breather means that I
stayed home on Monday nights
wow that was a breather I stayed home on
Monday nights
do you remember and I'm skipping ahead
tell me but do you remember the last
time you took a full week off No Wow no
there's no four weeks off this is what
you want to do in your life there's no
weeks off when you do when you do
Madison Square Garden that's you deserve
a week off until then I don't even know
what you're talking about
right I don't know what you're talking
about I didn't take a night off I didn't
take a holiday off I hated Christmas cuz
there was no comedy I started hating the
nights I couldn't do Kali that's when
you know you love something you love it
like I [ __ ] what are you talking about
so when all this started coming down the
pipe you know we've been going steady
since 2012 yeah all right
Podcast Road you know I've been a year
before I met you I was going on the road
heavy before I had mercy I was going on
the road heavy so for me I asked Rogan
the other in the podcast as he written
and he said no and I was very happy
because I am NOT written a joke either
I've written little things in there you
know you know I'm gonna use on stage yes
I can't lie to you but at that I'm
working on different things like I was
writing uh you know obviously nobody's
buying books right now whatever but I'm
still trying to write you know so I was
just trying to write it's interesting
that you asked that question
I was just trying to write the story of
me falling in love with Tommy how the
process happened like I still know my
ex-wife telling me I don't want to be
with you and me being so happy because
that was the only obstacle in my way
that I was trying to put a family
together that was the only obstacle in
my way for doing comedy I knew I could
do it but how was I gonna do it with a
young family that was the question and
again four people think I'm crazy
God [ __ ] opened up the door I made a
fall out of love with me and she dumped
me and one with another guy thank God if
that I wouldn't have been here so
everything happens for a reason right
so at that time it was now only 29 years
ago I had nothing going on I was broke
and I had nothing to lose
let me go for comedy I'm divorced I'm
broke I got nothing to lose there's
nothing you could do to me now I'm
already fifty thousand in debt and
that's climbing
well I can't I'm not gonna make any
money in comedy you can't throw me in
debtors prison there's no debtors prison
you know there's no Dennis prison so you
keep going but I fell in love with this
[ __ ] racket so when the possibility
in my mind I was a little upset you know
I enjoy leaving twice a month
it's my little six days and I get to
watch my teach my little computer I get
privacy I could think I missed my
daughter and my wife but I enjoy it
believe it or not I don't have a social
life my social life is the comedy store
when I go over that hill that's my
social life it's sad but it's true
okay it's not like I go somewhere once a
week where I play cards I hang out in
the men's choir I don't have any of that
[ __ ] all I have is the Comedy Store
right so when this went down
I've looked at this as a breather this
is a breather for a guy like me but it's
a well-deserved breather this is not
stopped but 29 years yeah
this train is not stopped I don't want
it to stop I never wanted it to stop
but sometimes you need to take a break
this is making me the reason why I
haven't written comedy my reason is
because I want it you know like things
are trending mmm and my mind things are
trending all the time right like you
think I wanted to start trending new
things I wanted my mind to start coming
up with new things
so whatever material I had before this
it's done yeah it's over with so when I
hit the stage
June 1st July 1st August 1st I'm
starting from scratch
yeah there's no way to go back yeah
that's it they did me a favor don't
worry I'm gonna put it back together and
you gotta put a lot of CD and put on the
CD before he's for three bucks or
something but for right now there's
nothing to think about all we could do
is take care of ourselves and get ready
for the next chapter of our lives
whatever it's gonna be we don't know you
you know right now you're gonna find out
people's true colors this is what's good
about this you're gonna find out about
people's true colors you're gonna see
what banks are willing to work with you
you know my friend brought up a great
point before you know a lot of these
banks are giving you 90 days without a
mortgage but at the end of those 90 days
you got to pay all three of those more
gas plus the fourth one so there's no
bargain here guys there's gonna be a by
the way people gonna be hurt and that
belts are gonna tighten people are gonna
lose their homes people are gonna lose
their businesses but on the bright side
it's a start for most people like my
uncle he's 80 [ __ ] - he couldn't wait
to get on that bar this just came the
answer I really this accelerated the
deal he's done good friend it's up for
sale it's up for sale it'll sell within
a month
Wow you know that's it that's it you
know today yesterday on Sunday a famous
owl and they had closed in Beverly Hills
really they're closing they closed
yesterday yeah because yeah they don't
know nobody knows the future right now
you're sitting there going I gotta pay
employees I gotta do this I gotta do
that I gotta do this I gotta do that
nobody [ __ ] knows yeah I'm hoping
there's some sort of there is a silver
lining yes I give you my [ __ ] word as
a man I've always had faith in what what
higher power I don't know but I've
always had faith and I'm telling you
guys please don't be down there's gonna
be a silver lining out of all this
there's gonna be a silver lining out of
all this we don't know what it is right
now so before you go down and start
writing yourself off and start packing
your bags I want you to think of the
silver lining that's gonna come from
this man listen I feel as bad as all you
do but I know I know there's a silver
lining in this we're all gonna learn
what we need what we don't need what we
can live with what we can't live with a
lot of people gonna go you know what the
cable got turned off and I've been five
for the last they you don't know what
you could live with them till you start
living without it you know I had a
friend of mine and said to me that he
cut his life down he cut his bills down
by 70 percent a year ago he says he did
the math one day and he goes you know
what canceled everything the water the
[ __ ] in
he bought a water a filter right and he
figured out that it's cheaper for the
filters and it's better for the thing he
figured out that he could live without
[ __ ] cable and he just uses Disney
Plus he figured out he told me all these
things that he could figure out and he's
a better man for it people gonna see
that
people will learn you were living on
$2,400 a month but now you're living on
15 and you're gonna figure out a way on
how to do it and make it work and you're
gonna put yourself in shock you're gonna
realize that a lot of [ __ ] you were
spending was garbage yeah you know
that's what you're gonna realize in this
a lot of this [ __ ] you with spending do
you really need that I found single yeah
do you relieved that I found what are
you gonna take pictures of misery a
[ __ ] empty bank account of people
crying what do you think big dessert
what are you gonna take pictures of yeah
what do you take pictures up it's over a
video of what somebody hanging
themselves what are you gonna take a
picture of so you gotta ask yourself
what you really [ __ ] need right now
you know cut the data down whatever the
[ __ ] you need to do you need to do it
and you're gonna see that you can live
without these things you know [ __ ]
this is expensive write it off you know
you're gonna learn nothing you can live
without soda you know there's gonna be a
lot of vegans pretty soon a lot of
vegans a lot of [ __ ] gonna be
eating beans and rice pretty soon okay
I've been eating beans and rice already
Ashley I blew a [ __ ] bean fart before
that would shave your eyebrows without a
razor you let my legs bleed no no no no
I mean beans already I'm prepared I
prepared myself and my family for this
you know for years I told my wife we
live in an earthquake zone buy two of
everything every time you go by do
peanut butters my two soups by two
Campbell's so I got I got more soup than
Campbell my last name should be Campbell
have you opened the peanut butter yet
that's all I'm saving that cuz I open a
peanut butter I'm good I pop that
[ __ ] open the other night
jelly say oh I can't wait nice job
peanut butter because you go through
phases of peanut butter jelly won't you
eat one you go a long time a nice peanut
butter on fresh Wonder Bread and I got
that's what I do at night dog before I
[ __ ] I saved my points for night time
I saved my [ __ ] eight points Oh
right before my wife goes to bed that's
when I turn the edibles on actually I
popped that last void I see where I'm at
cuz I start with the edibles about four
and seven cuz you get the leg going
enough is enough
the boredoms got add you know I'm saying
oh whoa can you talk to yourself for the
bottoms got add what did I mean get the
leg going yeah I like to like going you
know what he's been stiff all day you
gotta get the leg going [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] how you doing you
gotta get the leg going four o'clock I
popped my first [ __ ] edible oh I
don't do bong hits no more that much
like my bong is clean I look for the
today it's spotless why didn't you make
that decision to switch from smoking
edibles because first of all if I'm not
getting as high as I was smoking okay
that's number one number two my lungs
are shot and number three they said
right now if you're a smoker it's not a
good time to be a smoker yeah I was
thinking about smoke quitting smoking
for about a year now I've been thinking
about that I get high at the weirdest
times I don't get as high as I usually
get you know urban trees has some
[ __ ] serious weed and if that [ __ ]
ain't getting me high you know people
smoke my weed like I can't come back in
I know [ __ ] there's a lady close to
my house he's a nursing mother her
daughter plays at Mercy when she comes
over I bring her in the back and I give
her a bong hit one day I went back
inside he just left my wife give her a
[ __ ] hippie nobody that's my wife
giving me a bean
she was sitting at taking that'd be my
[ __ ] she gave her such an even
beating I thought my hearing aids were
gonna explode I was in the other room
I'm like my wife won't shut the [ __ ] up
I went in there the poor lady was
sitting there stuck to my wife stoned to
the guilt they should told my wife a
couple days later cuz you know what I
kind of quit smoking Joey's week cuz
that [ __ ] puts me out for two uh she
looked like thieves Delray when she
smoked the 24 K that day when Dean
smoked that's a teabag that's 24 karat
and that stuff just doesn't do anything
anymore no it's not it does I mean it
gives me a little buzz but look at last
week wait the mushrooms I swear to God I
ain't to mushroom caps and lately was
all [ __ ] up
yeah they weren't right through me I
[ __ ] spit him the [ __ ] out but I try
to switch it up like I'll switch up
edibles I got a thousand milligrams
brownies from George Perez my brother
Perez stories I got [ __ ] the ABX
capsules from my man Sam Tripoli and my
man Justin over at a BX and I have the
thing I gave you two quickies oh my god
I got that so I'd go on between three
edibles so I don't get [ __ ] used to
any of them I don't build the tolerance
against any of them [ __ ] know that I've
been hired almost every night there's my
live it's a lot I don't know how you do
it that much I'm sick and tired of being
bored see you know how long can you be
[ __ ] bored for us so the edibles at
least breaks up the [ __ ] monotony I'm
not popular mandate in the morn that's a
problem but come [ __ ] a four o'clock I
got a go yeah I also don't watch the
news no more oh no there's no reason to
Watson there's no more this so it's
[ __ ] depressing so I don't watch the
news no more but I promise you
[ __ ] there's a silver lining in
all this we don't know what it is yet I
know you guys are [ __ ] probably going
go [ __ ] yourself Joey trust me I've been
around for a long time and I've been
through a lot of [ __ ] this is bad but
it's gonna pass and you're gonna be fine
if there's something you want to do this
is the time to do it because you have
nothing to lose I know schools are
closed right now but I was thinking that
the other day I might if I was at my age
right now and wanted to go back to
school this is the time to do it well
they offered free online classes are
they a bunch of colleges Wow
there's a bunch of people doing the free
online stuff right now you know there's
a bunch of stuff for you not to be bored
trust me this week I'm gonna start on my
room my back office is a [ __ ]
nightmare this week I'm gonna do a
[ __ ] Theroux cleanse of that thing
you know there's a thousand things you
could be doing not to be bored and not
to lose your mind so you don't smack
your wife or beat up your kid or punch
your brother in the stomach
choked your mother there's no reason for
this [ __ ] there's no reason for and you
look at me going Joey it's easy for you
to say no I'm telling you guys I'm
panicking too you know you got you guys
know I said [ __ ] some panic attacks but
this is just it's gonna pass and I'll be
here with you taking bullets eating [ __ ]
we're gonna do the podcast as long as we
can leak coffee say no we don't need no
leather we just saw the cops are gonna
go to church we're going around the
corner get out of the way
what am i John Jones you gonna pull me
over and she don't have no God that was
the weirdest story of the [ __ ] week
really yeah I'm very sad about that
I love John I love John as a friend
I've always loved John I've known John
Rogan introduced me to John way before
he was a champion and I always had great
conversations of them and I was very
surprised about the drug allegations I
really really was and I thought he had
everything under control
this weeks you know the thing that
killed him was he put up attack a tweet
that said stay home everybody and front
of the TV you can't [ __ ] this up and not
even oh yeah and not even a week later
does he get in trouble for shooting off
a gun and drinking tequila you know I
haven't watched the arrest videos and
nothing they're all over online it's
none of my business my heart just goes
out to him and I'm gonna tell you what
happened in this situation okay when
Europe I know this years ago when all
this stuff started going off with the
podcast Rogan and people people started
asking me differently you know it makes
people act differently and I had a few
people that were hitting me on Facebook
there was a couple people a couple names
that you know that I'm not gonna throw
under the bus because I don't give a
[ __ ] but that was lobby boy emailing me
be my friend you know not trying to be
my facebook friend but trying to hang
out you know I'm saying and I've always
told people something I've never really
talked to you guys about as much as when
you want to change your life you got to
get away from people that take you down
who you hang out with doesn't make a
[ __ ] difference in your life trust
what I'm telling you who you consider
your friends who you consider to watch
you and when you get into a certain
light in your life you know for me I'm
just a dirty [ __ ] comic dog that got
lucky you know I got a GED that was a
loser for a long time was a petty thief
and I applied my mind to something and I
did the best I could with it you know
but for some reason people get into this
position and they surround themselves
with people who tell them yes
right you know people tell you you're
great that's the funniest thing I've
ever heard
and I gotta tell you something if I'm
lying to you it feels good it feels good
it feels good when but I want it to come
from your soul I also want you to tell
me when I suck you know when my ages or
whatever around and then I have a good
set I have a good set but if I have a
bad set they come up to me and say I was
pretty good I get angry deep down inside
because that was pretty [ __ ] bad I
know it I know when I do something
pretty [ __ ] bad and that was pretty
[ __ ] bad
I lost hard on yourself in there you
have to be hard on yourself when you're
a stand-up comic right
we live off our work so we have to
choose our words correctly so when I
place a word somewhere wrong I do
something wrong I do beat myself up we
have to have I just didn't start doing
this yesterday I'm an old man I've been
doing this for 29 [ __ ] years there's
no era you know you know it's like when
I told you guys before when we went into
this [ __ ] seclusion [ __ ] it was rough
on me for a week and then in my journal
one day I wrote something
that changed my outlook on everything I
wrote that at the end of the day I'm not
a comic I'm the man of the house strive
to change my ways that was done after
the first week of whatever you call this
quarantine right with my wife and my
daughter whirring listen I'd be lying to
you if I tell you that there weren't
times when I got upset I was getting
upset at little things like my daughter
leaving the light on in the room in or
something I was getting upset and I
caught myself I caught myself and I said
I can't get upset
that's what cabin fever does to you like
this is the beginnings of cabin fever I
have to learn how to deal with cabin
fever so even when our line yeah because
I live in Colorado and that's where the
shining happened yeah the movie The
Shining and there was cabin fever and
they always spoke about it people go
crazy up here in the snow and the went
there and what people don't know is that
there's an offseason and Aspen and all
those ski resorts have an offseason so a
lot of people leave so you live in a
Snowmass Village you move up there like
the middle of October you get yourself a
job for the winter and then November
15th the ski lifts open and you go
straight to April 15 April 16th that
town becomes a ghost town that's when
you go home and see your mother for a
month because all the snow melts all
that snow starts to melt you can't do
any construction you can't cut grass
there's really nothing viable to do the
supermarkets open for limited hours a
lot of the businesses closed they only
open for the seasons so Aspen has an off
season from April 15 to about May 15th
or May 30th then things start picking up
remember I told you I moved to Snowmass
April 25th of 1983 took me about two
weeks to get a job and I'm a hustler
it took me about two weeks to get a job
because there was nothing there
nothing was really open yet the streets
estates nose
it still snows a lot you know like April
then the April still snowy so every year
my wife at the time my girlfriend will
go home and see her parents in Boulder
and I would stay up in Snowmass by
myself
me and the dog and a blender and videos
yeah so I would shoot down to the video
store I had the keys to it I ran the
video store command the video so I would
go down the hill take two movies out and
run back up there I had a punching bag
in the garage and I had a job to do I
had to shovel the property so for 30
days that's all I did
I think heaven was hit the bag shovel
the snow throw snowballs for the dog go
to the video store and go shopping
there's nothing open there's no bars the
coke dealer was always open that
[ __ ] I don't go nowhere
he's open 24/7 so that month I got used
to living by myself so when this all
went down I took uh I took a journal and
I wrote that I'm the man of the house
you know I have to have a face it has to
be happy at all times to [ __ ] runs
downhill if I'm upset my why should I be
upsetting the baby's gonna be upset you
know after my mother died and I remember
like a year afterward I was having a
drink with one of her friends this book
yeah not though he was the bookmaker
that would always cup his hand and go
like that and go by and fart and stuff
and he told me a story he said that he
remembered when I was in the hospital my
mother would get to the hospital 15
minutes before visitation and she would
cry downstairs in the lobby and then she
would wipe herself up and and then wait
for him and his brother and it would
come upstairs and see me that my mother
needed carriage to come upstairs the
same because I was her only son and she
was care for me so she would cry but she
would never let me see her cry like when
she would walk up her courage is always
big so Mike Harajuku I wouldn't be
scared right so I decided that the meter
I'm the man louse at the end of the day
this is no folklore this ain't no story
I'm the [ __ ] man house so after act
like it my behavior has to be happy no
matter what I'm going through I gotta be
in a good mood if I'm going through
anxiety I gotta be respectful to my wife
my wife is over there dealing with mercy
right now you know yes say my wife got
to deal with it for two hours did they
do like a church Wow
because it stead of going to church on a
Sunday my wife takes are in the back and
does [ __ ] Bible study oh yeah we're
doing everything in the house that's
really impressive dude I mean nothing
you were like an extremely angry person
before but like every year where I'm
Christmas you always tell me how much I
hate this time of year when no one does
anything so I just imagine two months of
that would be driving you insane
underneath the core it is driving me
insane anybody who knows me knows I'm
going crazy but back to what you said
there's nothing I could do I'm not a
scientist I don't have syringes for
grads hanging around a microscope what
can I do what do you want me to do you
want me to bust out my chemistry set can
for sure this [ __ ] I can't cure this
[ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ] they do
so you know there's not that it's beyond
our control so you have to learn to
adapt to this type of lifestyle that's
it that's it I get to see you again this
week you know and that's it we've been
keeping away from each other we've been
trying to quarantine you know we were
trying to the more you quarantine the
better you are I mean I don't want to
sound cliche stay the [ __ ] in if you get
an Amazon box delivered let it get
delivered put it in area
wipe it down and don't open it for a day
my wife doesn't open everything that day
she leaves it we put in the garage we
what picking up with gloves put in the
garage
we don't even walk through the house so
I mean I don't know I was small places
yeah I don't even walk through the house
I put in a garage and I'd [ __ ] leave
it there for two days then I open it up
I just got protein powder I had no
protein powder all week
I was living without my little protein
shakes I just got honored that sent me
some more stuff I got you know you have
to just it's a different lifestyle guys
and it's not something that you could
tiptoe around you know you see I got the
ozium here my desk I got the CBD lime I
got the [ __ ] cream next to me to keep
me moisturize all we could do is take
care of ourselves as far as comedy I
don't know what to tell you
you know you think about it you think
this is gonna open up no it's going to
be 10 people 20 people 50 people a
hundred people
it'll be nice no it'll be stuck next to
all those people in the club yeah no
that'll be nice that'll be nice for a
while yeah that'll be nice for a while
but once these animals can get them in
they gotta make that money too yeah
nobody's gonna make money so I feel bad
for everybody I know everybody's itchy
everybody's going through a hard time
and all I could say is next time you go
to your supermarket the CVS get a
notebook get a notebook and [ __ ]
write out whatever the [ __ ] you're
feeling and you'll feel right and that's
how I'm keeping it together to be honest
to you my notebook is my [ __ ]
therapist that's how I'm keeping it
together you know I've been smoking pot
for a long [ __ ] time I should be
ashamed of myself but I'm not because
when you smoke pot early on like I smoke
pot when I was 13 14 15 to really not
makes you very self-conscious when you
smoke pot if you get high sometimes you
it's like you leave your body and look
within and you could see all your little
flaws you could say you don't know how
many times I'll get high and go [ __ ] I
can't believe I said that me eighth
grade yeah I can't believe I said that
on stage the other night you know I
can't believe you know because it makes
you very self-conscious it gives you an
opportunity to step out of yourself and
look within you know and this is what
I've been doing for the last three weeks
it's just looking within see where I can
strengthen myself
I'm 57 years old I don't know how much
time I have in this planet you know all
I know is I think my heart medication I
read them a little aspirin I work on I
lift weights I stretch and I'm just
trying to be the best version of me you
know I got problems just like you guys
everybody we all got problems here but
who cares right now right now we got
bigger fish to fry right now you take
care of your family you gotta keep your
parents up you know they feel like
monsters now our parents we can't even
go see him I know my kid go see him my
brother is he's actually got an airbnb
with his girlfriend for a month in
Massachusetts because New York so bad
right now and he said he told my mom
listen you can't come visit this isn't a
vacation he's gotta be away from your
mom for two weeks three weeks and then
he could go see you little by little you
know but we can't get mom sick you can't
get grandpa sick no and that's what the
whole point of this and you can't listen
this ain't even hold anymore now they're
saying they killed an infant you know
what the [ __ ] this could do I didn't do
this podcast today to [ __ ] scare you
even more III did this podcast to give
you a light to let you know there's a
light there's gonna be light man trust
what I'm telling you I haven't been
through a pandemic before but I've been
through what's called problems and you
know what when I was looking at the end
of the world it really was in the end of
the world it was just another another
day in paradise so grab on to this hold
on to the best you can you know dwarf
ape work let the government know where
you are so you can [ __ ] get your
checks and began coming to you and yes
unemployment's on the way but if you're
a sucker and you're really waiting for
an employment to save your dreams you're
killing yourself to live if you got a
family [ __ ] head to the nearest
grocery store they need stalkers like a
[ __ ] that my buddy
I called my buddy and he got a job three
days later they called him I think he
starts next week working at ShopRite 422
or [ __ ]
Wow another nine plus a thank you to all
those everyone who still is working I
wouldn't want to be working out in
public right now listen I want to thank
the [ __ ] police officers I want to
thank the nurses the doctors the
restaurant workers everybody who's out
there right now I appreciate you with
everything I got and when the [ __ ]
storm clears
trust me we're gonna [ __ ] lay it out
Fiat the boiler will line up benefits
for nurses benefits for hospitals you
know I'm looking at this I'm dropping
off some food this week at the North
Hollywood they just opened up a shelter
last night and North Hollywood that it's
a co big place and they're looking for
towels sweatpants because they don't
want people to be uptight there so it
look like sweatpants and shirts I'm
cleaning out everything tomorrow I'm
taking food over there I got some extra
corn and [ __ ] like that but I mean the
corn I have I can't eat all of it I got
more creamed corn than [ __ ] then that
company does so there's a couple things
we're gonna give away and I write them a
check in the name of the church you know
they're homeless you know that's the
only right get out
you know I've called the Comedy Store
and I told them once this goes up we're
gonna do something for the waitresses
and waiters if they stick around you
know you got to do what you got to do
right now this listen right now you've
had a job for a long time and they lay
you off
you couldn't collect unemployment and
you got another way to make money listen
the only loyalty you have is to your
family that's the only law do you have
it's to your family and to yourself
everything else is background music you
got to keep the lights on so I wish you
well thank you for listening today I got
no dates for you cuz they no [ __ ]
dates so it's fun we could just relax
sit back and be [ __ ] buddies for once
and not worry about [ __ ] comedy and
just have a great [ __ ] time there's
what I'm talking about it
like I said I've gone through this [ __ ]
all my life to me there's just another
day in paradise we got to cut back to
just but at the same time you got to
move forward and
that's what I want all you [ __ ]
to do kick this [ __ ] virus leak
anyway that's it I'll see you guys
Wednesday morning tip-top Magoo ready to
go hold on I love you [ __ ] but
on my heart I really [ __ ] do I
appreciate you for listening I
appreciate you for supporting us and I
appreciate you busting my balls and
still being around
it's a tough time we got each other and
I mean that with all my heart I love you
guys I hope you will have a great day
and go out there and [ __ ] plan your
next move there's always a silver lining
kick this [ __ ] melee
[Music]